All right, so let's think this through, what's going on here. So going back to the formula for a second.
Remember all the clauses end up being in these groups, so there's one clause for each node
that says that that node has to have one of the k colors.
That's going to total up to n clauses in the formula.
Then, for each pair of colors, we have to exclude that they are both true for every nodes.
This is for every node, for every pair of colors in the node, there's a clause.
For every node, for every pair of colors, there's a clause. All right.
And that covers making sure that there's a color assignment that make sense.
Then for each color, for each edge in a graph, we have a clause
that excludes that that color is shared on both ends of that graph.
That's for each color, for each edge, we have a clause. So that ends up being the total.
There's no other clauses that we need to consider here that captures the notion of k color ability.
You can just plug these numbers in 8+(832/2) is 32, 3*20 is 60, 92 was what I get,
but the important thing that I wanted you to get at is this formula here,
which most importantly is polynomial in the size of the graph.
We have a graph of a given size that from that we generate a formula
and the formula has given size and that size is polynomial.
That's good because then when we run--imagine that we have some kind of satisfiability algorithm
that runs in polynomial time--it's running on a polynomial size input, so it's not like we're running
a polynomial time algorithm on an exponential size input, which would take exponential time to run.
This way, it really does run in polynomial time.